or let's go ahead and get started so
hello everyone welcome today's talk is
by depth Woodcock and it's my privilege
to introduce her I mean pretty much
everyone knows Deb and right now she is
and a clinical analyst for our clinical
informatics group but she's worn many
many hats and D Mike's she's a master
student and presenting her thesis today
but she's also been a program manager
for the ID of the informatics discovery
lab she's ta many courses including a
course I'm teasing sister and before she
came to be my there has a bachelor's
with a double major in physics and
astronomy and an MBA and she's
collecting many many degrees and is well
on her way to her masters so with that
let me turn it over to death Woodcock
who's going to be presenting her
research today thank you dr. mohan and
it's great to see everybody here
particularly since there's no pizza
being further appreciated sounds like
I'm getting a little bit of an echo next
is that all right great so again thank
you and thank you for for coming to hear
me talk about my thesis proposal my
master's thesis proposal which is titled
effects of medical scrubs on patient
trust in a nutshell over the last eight
years or so there seems to have been a
great increase in the number of medical
scribes being used in healthcare and the
medical scribe is an individual who
comes alongside a provider and helps
them document in the electronic health
record during a patient encounter
despite this increase in the number of
scribes there's not very much known
about the effects of scribes
particularly on patient care and
particularly from the patient's
perspective and as a result health care
organizations and providers who are
using scribes don't have a lot of
guidance in terms of how to use them
effectively how to avoid problems with
them and so I thought this might be a
really interesting area
it to look into particularly in the side
of patient care and from the patient's
perspective because those seem to be
gaps and I'll get into those in a minute
or two so describes had actually been
used for thousands of years to document
medicine this is a shot from something
called the Ebers papyrus which is among
some of the oldest medical medically
preserved documentation and it dates
from about 1550 bc that's forward to
today and a busy emergency department
the first references to medical scribes
in modern medical or literature occur in
the 1970s referring to scribe systems
used to document in paper charts annual
in emergency departments today scribes
are still widely used in emergency
departments this time documenting in
electronic health records and they're
also used in outpatient settings and in
specialty such as orthopedic surgery
where documentation time competes with
time that could be used on potentially
very lucrative revenue generating
activities I thought we played the
where's waldo so can you spot subscribes
in this picture and actually I don't
know for sure that these are scribes but
if they were scribes so this is this is
where they'd be located and so you can
start to get a sense for some of the
challenges that might be involved with
scribing particularly in an environment
like this a little bit more about the
roles of medical scribes what's trying
to do varies greatly from organization
organization even within organisations
by department to department and by
provider to provider but in general
medical scribes participate with the
provider in preparing for the patient
visit usually reviewing the patient's
information in their chart on the
electronic health record then they
accompany the provider into the room and
they document progress notes and seen
some examples here for the kinds of
things that they they document during
the during the visit and they may help
find information either within the
patient charts it might be in a
different encounter
or in a different part of the chart or
external to the patient's chart if the
provider needs information during the
visit after the visit the provider and
the scribe typically confer and if
there's anything additional it needs to
be documented the provider will tell the
described at that time and then the
provider reviews corrects if necessary
and then signs off or tests to describe
note and this is actually a little
screen shot of the bottom of ascribed
progress note showing the attestation
and the signature of the provider would
ordinarily go down here underneath so as
I said the number of subscribers appears
to be growing pretty rapidly this is not
this is not a chart of the scribe growth
this is a chart obviously of EHR
adoption rates in the United States over
the last 12 2010 22 2015 so for that
period but ascribed advocacy group
estimates that in 2015 and were 15,000
scribes in the United States and the
same group estimates that by 2020 there
will be a hundred 100,000 scribes in the
United States so again take it for what
it's worth it's from a group that that
promotes subscribe use so those those
statistics in or that that those numbers
may be you know again taken with a grain
of salt but there the growth may be
associated with this increase in EHR
adoption rate you can't obviously prove
prove causality there but we do know
that EHR adoption results in both
benefits and unintended consequences so
looking into this a little bit further
when you talk about the addition of the
electronic health record to the patient
encounter for thousands of years again
we've had this relationship between the
patient and the provider in sort of a
dyad and yes the provider might have
been documenting on papyrus or they
might have been documenting in a paper
chart but fundamentally the provider was
focused on the patient with the
additional the electronic health record
we've now moved to a triad where the
provider is not only interacting with
the patient but they have to interact
with the computer and as you can imagine
or you can from your own experience the
experience of chatting with somebody in
writing
very different from trying to talk with
someone have a meaningful conversation
and be looking for information in the
computer while while you're having that
conversation it requires providers to
engage cognitively in a way that they've
never had to engage before and that's
led to as I said you know numerous flow
intended or it seems well documented
unintended consequences for those of you
who have not seen what a provider might
see when they open a patient's encounter
here's one this is there's no thi and
this is actually off of epics one of
epics environments hosted on the
Internet what I wanted to give you an
idea of all the things that they might
have to look at there's guidance up here
and men use their menus down here which
has been actually recently greatly
simplified there's all kinds of
information and tabs up here depending
on what selections you make other
information appears and so the provider
is is trying to speak to the patient
understand their problems and assess the
situation and do clinical reasoning at
the same time they're having to use
cognate cognitive energy if you will to
think about where they're supposed to be
in the chart and what's going on so the
use of the electronic health records and
this lack of usability if you will and
the fact that it's not it's not
something that's easy for a provider
necessarily to use least just to several
things that are really frustrations for
providers one is that it increases
charting time on the order of hours a
day instead of going home at the end of
the day and finishing your paper
documentation providers often have to
spend hours afterwards continuing to
find what they need and document in the
electronic health record as I mentioned
as you can see it's also the distraction
factor right of having to do that but
there's also this this issue of the
physical barrier that the computer
creates between the patient and provider
even if the computer isn't literally
between the patient provider as in this
drawing you can see this illustration
you can see she's off to the side and I
like the fact that the providers hair is
a little bit untidy and she
sitting sort of to the side she's half
facing the patient has to the computer
and the very sort of trim and pulled
together patient is leaning forward in
anticipation trying to get the providers
attention I just is one of my favorite
illustrations basics because I think it
captures some of those challenges and
those subtleties very nicely so it's not
perhaps surprising that many providers
have turned to medical scribes as a way
to mitigate some of these issues around
the time it takes to chart the
distraction and the the interposition of
the computer between the patient and the
provider because if the chart is being
taken care of by the scribe then the
provider is free to focus more fully on
the patient and their needs that said
implementing that describes is not
without its challenges one of them is
that because the scribe industry has
grown so quickly it is not there it's
very different variation throughout the
industry in in many different areas one
is this idea of what what is the scribes
role and here you can see two
definitions like sort of a big gorillas
in health care the Joint Commission and
their definition of what describe is and
then the Senate center for medicare and
medicaid services in their definition
and you can see that those two
definitions is going even agree there is
no overarching regular regulation or
oversight of the scribe industry and
there also is no standardized training
for medical scribes and the net result
is that health care organizations and
providers are essentially left to
recruit train and operate with scribes
any way they see fit because there's
nobody sending any boundaries for them
so that that might raise some concerns
so coming back to our triad with the
computer now in an effort to mitigate
this interaction we've added the scribe
to the encounter and as you can see from
the center line here yes you may have
reduced the providers interaction with
the computer during the encounter but
you added another interaction
here you've added the interaction
between the provider and the scribe just
by virtue of the presence of another
person in the room there there is a
unconscious as well as a conscious need
to engage with that person so you've
added complexity to this system in an
effort to try to mitigate this this
issue or the issues posed by that
relationship so as I said when a scribe
enters the room they become an actor in
that encounter and they may alter the
way that communications have them even
though they're not interacting directly
with the patient because they're
demanding some level of attention from
the provider in order to do their work
they they will affect the way the
provider ex interacts with a patient as
well so some suggest perhaps that having
ascribed in the room might inhibit
patients from talking with their
providers particularly around
emotionally or physically sensitive
subjects and some suggest that the
scribe may actually enhance the patient
provider relationship there's really no
evidence out there and nobody has really
studied which if one or the other or a
little bit of both might that might
happen so that made me wonder whether
the effect of the scribe on this
interaction and on the trust that
patients have for the providers might be
affected by introducing describes into
the encounter so let's talk about trust
for a minute while there are many types
of trusts and meant test and many
definitions of trust it's widely
considered that interpersonal trust
forms ability the basis of the
relationship between the patient and the
provider and it has been shown that
higher levels of interpersonal trust can
actually affect patient outcomes and
also processes such as increased
adherence to medication and improved
glycemic control so there's a good basis
for
trying to encourage trust and support
trust in the patient provider
relationship closely related to the
concept of interprofessional chart
interprofessional interpersonal trust is
this concept of collaborative trust
which has become more prominent as
patient engagement and patient
empowerment has become more more
important in healthcare I really like
the soups really like this photo a lot
the definition here is from Carol bova
who is in investigator at the University
of Massachusetts who looks at who
studies patient provider trust
particularly in diverse patient
populations and also on care teams that
involve multiple types of providers so
not just physicians but also nurse
practitioners and physician assistants
and so forth so I got interested in her
work because she was taking a little bit
broader view and since I'm studies
interested in studying scribes I thought
this might be a promising direction to
promising information to look at so Bova
suggests that you could you could look
at this collaborative trust conceptual
framework as comprising three elements
and I'm going to read a little bit from
her definitions of them because she has
a nice job interpersonal connection
which relates to the emotional bonding
which occurs when patient and provider
demonstrate caring sincerity and the
ability to rate relate to one another
respectful communication which occurs
with patient and provider demonstrate
respect for each other and protect
confidential confidentiality and privacy
professional partnering which involves
sharing knowledge in a way that's
understandable demonstrating commitment
to the relationship and reciprocity
between the patient and the healthcare
provider so again by virtue of their
presence in the room it would seem to me
that the medical scribe has the
potential to affect any and all of these
elements and it suggests that MIT may be
important to understand how the
introduction of patients scribes into
into clinical encounters may affect
collaborative trust
so taking a step back let's let's look
at what's already been studied about
scribes and put it in context you can
see my search strategy here I won't go
through it line by line but essentially
I searched on the term is medical scribe
or scribe or team documentation which
I'm starting to see more frequently now
in the literature I didn't I didn't
constrain it by dates and I did
reference chaining so as I started to
identify pieces of literature I started
to look at their references and work my
way back through them to find additional
articles of interest and out of that the
period from 2008 2017 I was able to
identify 26 published studies on scribes
and this is just a chart that kind of
gives you an overview the takeaways here
or that the majority of the studies that
have been done thus far have been first
of all in emergency departments which no
surprise given what I said earlier and
also focus on quantitative or
operational financial metrics primarily
the areas where there are some gaps
where there hasn't been a lot of work is
in outpatient or ambulatory clinics and
also on some of the more qualitative
aspects of scribes such as perceptions
of scribes from various populations and
so it struck me from looking at this as
though this this area this general area
of this matrix might be an appropriate
area to to focus on taking a more
patient centric view and also looking at
something that looking at an issue that
is more related to to care the actual
provision of care which brings me to my
project goal which is to explore the
effects of medical scribes I'm patient
provider trust in an outpatient setting
from the patient's perspective using
bobas collaborative trust framework as a
guide and there are four specific aims
to support that goal the overarching aim
is to identify variations in patient
provider trust and
patients perceptions and scribes between
patients who have seen have participated
in scribes assisted encounters and
patients who have not and so you can see
the sub aims there are two first
describe the characteristics subscribe
assistant encounters how do they differ
from non scribe assistive encounters to
examine the relationship between overall
patient provider trust prescribe
assisted and non assisted encounters and
we'll talk about how we're going to go
about doing that in a second and then to
examine the relationships between
patient perceptions and scribes and
patient demographic variables the study
designed since we don't know a lot about
this space and we're still trying to
figure out what's going on is
exploratory and descriptive I propose to
use mixed methods so a mix of
qualitative and quantitative methods to
do this study when you're looking at a
new phenomenon or an emerging phenomenon
and it's and I would propose almost
anything it it is valuable to look at it
from multiple perspectives and using
multiple methods you'll get richer data
from that you'll be able to see where
there are intersections and triangulate
on that information as well as being
kinds of things that pop up using one
method that maybe didn't emerge from
using another again the study is patient
focused we're going to look at a series
of snapshot encounters so I'm gonna
study one patient encounter at a time
it's not longitudinal it's singular and
then there will be three stages of the
study one is preparation because I don't
know what I don't know right now both
spend some time trying to figure out
some of that before I get going and then
data in collection analysis which I'll
go into in a minute you'll see the three
pieces of that and then finishing with
evaluation now this is this Chevron
diagram is a little bit misleading
because in reality what I'll be doing as
I learn things through this process is
looping back and helping and in
incorporating the things that I learned
into the
these earlier phases because I'll for
example i'll be at observing a patient
in an encounter administering the
questionnaire and doing the interview
all at one time and out of that i may
learn something that i can then take
into the next patient encounter so it's
it's an iterative process and it's a
process really of discovery in order to
support future hypotheses about what may
be going on with medical arrives the
setting for the study I propose is one
outpatient clinic that seemed to be most
feasible to me and the setting that I'm
proposing is the Center for Women's
Health the OB GYN clinic and as you can
see there are six different
subspecialties or specialties in the
Center for Women's Health and as you
might start to think about this or the
kinds of patients you might have might
think well you know general patients can
be maybe a little bit different than a
somebody who's seeing physician or
provider for for a pregnancy that's high
risk so we start to think about some of
the variation that may occur based on
the types of patients in our you know
population I liked this the setting for
a few reasons one is that they have the
most the greatest number of providers
scribe teams at ohsu so there's a rich
environment and really could maximize
the amount of data that I could collect
the other is that they were an early
adopter of scribes and so they had a
fair amount of experience now subscribes
typically will cycle through the
department so there's always turn over
but providers at least have had
familiarity and management has had
administration has had experience
working with medical scribes and there's
there's a lot of information and
background to be mined there within
ob/gyn obd1 uses if you'd like to call
it the student a student scribe model
whereby pre-med pre-nursing in pre pas
come in and work for a year or two and
then they cycle out and they go on to
graduate school to go on to med school
to go into nursing school in the in the
meantime they've gathered really
valuable experience and contacts in the
environment and the environment the
clinic has gained scribes who are very
invested in what they're doing because
they know that this is part of their
future training within OBGYN there is
what I call one of many providers scribe
relationship which means that every
provider works with a single scribe but
scribes may work with multiple providers
in sort of a pooled setting and some
providers don't use scribes so this
thing to be a good setting to select the
participants in the study will be
patients providers I anticipate
encouraging five to ten providers with
scribes and five to ten provider scribe
teams to work with me on the project and
they will all be consented according to
ohsu IRB protocol with respect to ethics
and integrity of the study patient
privacy is obviously a key concern and
if you think about the sensitivity of
what goes on in ob/gyn you can see that
it's very clear that I will have to be
very respectful of my interactions with
the patients regardless of what the
reason for their visit is and you're
willing to step out of the room if they
feel uncomfortable at all the last thing
I want to do is is have a negative
effect on the patient provider
relationship myself we'll talk a little
bit about this issue of reactivity a
little bit later on you'll see that
there's a component of interviews with
my study and those interviews will be
conducted in a separate room so again
trying to respect the patient's privacy
with respect to data confidentiality
we'll be identifying all the patient
data collecting the data on a secure
ohsu laptop and storing it on ohsu
zapper
HIPAA compliant cloud storage system box
so now let's dig down into some of the
real meat potatoes of the of the
specific aims and the methods the first
first name or 1a and not the overarching
aim where the first the first one under
it is to describe characters and
subscribe assisted encounters I propose
to do this with two phases of clinical
observation again it's patient's
individual providers and providers
scribe teams in clinic and phase one of
the observation will encompass about six
encounters / provider for about 30 to 60
encounters and another six encounters
provider scribe team for another 30 to
60 the purpose as you can see is for me
really to become immersed in and
familiar with the ob/gyn environments in
which i'll be i'll be doing this study
building rapport both of the providers
and the staff because they're going to
be seeing you around and I want them to
trust me in to feel that they can come
to me and share information and I'll
start to become familiar if I see
encounters where patients are were
scribes are being used and encounters
whether or not I'll start to notice what
those differences are and all of that
will help inform creation of the
observation guide on being used in the
second phase so during phase two which
is really why start collecting data I am
anticipating six to twelve observing six
to twelve encounters / provider for a
total of sixteen counters and I'll talk
in a minute excuse me I'll talk in a
minute about why 60 and same thing for
the for the provider scribe team and the
purpose for this observation is really
to capture the behaviors exhibited
during these encounters based on what I
perceived to be the important factors
that are associated with these subscribe
assistant encounters and then I've
created the observation guide around in
addition there are always things that
pop up that you don't anticipate and
that's some of the most interesting data
that you collect so i'll also be keeping
unstructured field notes and demographic
information will also be collected
point with respect to data analysis what
I'll be doing is personally transcribing
the field notes that I take and
performing primary coating on the the
docket the field notes and typically
when you read field notes during your
interview notes you don't just read them
once you read them multiple times
because your glean something new every
time you read them so you read them
several times and then once I've done
that because my perspective is only one
perspective what will also do is invite
some subject matter experts two to three
subject matter experts to come alongside
and also look at the field note data and
do some coding themselves and we we may
use a card sword technique in order to
triangulate and see if we come up with
common themes and sub seems by doing
that and that helps support the validity
of this method if it was just me my
opinion that's one thing when you have
several people involved you get at least
multiple perspective you can't ever get
all perspectives so you get multiple
perspectives and then finally what we'll
be doing is once we've come up with
those things we'll be doing what is
known as member checking which is to go
back to in this case the clinical
informatics Department and the described
program manager to say here's what we're
returning up is what do you think of
this is there anything here that we
should be aware of or there any
subtleties that we're missing because
you're the expert in this in this area
moving on to specific aim one b which is
examining the relationship between
overall patient provider trust subscribe
assisted and nondescript assisted
encounters again same groups that I'm
observing and the purpose of this this
method is to measure the level of
overall patient provider trust and we
start to get this triangulation going
right so we've done some observation now
we're going to we're going to do
something where we actually measure the
level of trust for these two groups and
that helps us to triangulate on on the
data we've already collected and started
to analyze
I proposed using a trust questionnaire
that is was actually Carol Bobo's that
has been validated and I'll talk a
little bit about how it's been validated
later but I'll administer it
face-to-face immediately following the
observation so the idea of the flow is
that when a patient is asked at the
beginning of their visit when they check
in if they're they'll be told about the
study asked if they're interested in
participating and if they are part of
the condition where the conditions is
that they're able to stay for 15 minutes
or so after their visit to be able to
have a conversation with me and if they
don't want to do that that's perfectly
fine go ahead and move on okay okay so
data collection continued so let me tell
you a little bit about this validated
instrument as I mentioned it was
developed by Carol Bova based on our
collaborative trust conceptual framework
it never measured its levels of overall
patient provider trust so it doesn't
make me to do with scribes this is just
measuring baseline trust I has been
validated both for driver risk care
teams and patient populations and I like
that because we certainly have diverse
patient populations here at ohsu I don't
know what I'm going to find at in the
center for women's health but it's
conceivable I can't believe I just said
that that that the population that I
study will over the samples that I study
will be will be diverse and I will be
administering it face to face and it's
nice that she has both validated it for
face-to-face administration and
self-report so you could hand somebody a
paper and ask them to send it in and
that's their city valid you don't want
to mix those two things within one study
but so we're going to strive for
face-to-face administration the survey
itself is or the questionnaire is 13
likert scale questions and one of the
questions is reverse coded to do again
try to generate internal validity for
the for the instrument and it scores of
0 2 52 in anticipate in less than 10
minutes to complete the survey so bulova
has in the development of this
instrument implemented it ravenna
stirred it in a primary care setting
that's one of the things that we know
about
that's already been collected using this
instrument and so what I'm doing now is
I'm looking for clues that might help me
think about how I might use this in an
ob/gyn environment particularly when you
see patients in a general ob/gyn setting
where they're coming in may be four
annual well-woman visits or more routine
things in many cases women view there
neither gynecologist as their primary
care provider they may not ever see a
primary care provider until some other
kind of health issue crops up so at
least for a portion of the sample that I
am anticipating recruiting for this
study that the primary carer ob/gyn
connection is that's plausible you could
make that maybe not so much with some of
the other types of patients will be
seeing but i wanted to be very aware of
what I was doing as I was looking at
this primary care data set also have to
be aware of the fact that she was using
this data or she was collecting it in
order to test the validity of her
instrument not to do the kinds of work
that I'm doing and so I have to be aware
of the purpose behind it also her data
are include female and male in OBGYN I'm
going to be seeing female patients only
and I also know a little bit about the
data I don't know much about the
distribution of the data but I do know
that the data are ordinal because their
scores based on this 0 2 52 scale and
that the mean was 53 sorry 45.3 when she
administered it with a median of 49 so
that's a pretty food distribution to the
right it seems to suggest that people
generally more positive in their scores
than been negative and as you can see we
also have a standard deviation here for
the overall unfortunately I don't have
information yet on median or standard
deviation or range for women only I'm
trying to get that information from her
and so if I do that that will help under
me understand this data a little bit
better so how would I use this in in
administering the questionnaire well
first
I need to divide I need to find find two
samples one is patients who have just
had a scribe assisted OBGYN encounter
and a group of patients who have had
their ob/gyn accountant without a scribe
and that brings us the sample size
estimation so I'm going to unpack this
statement of it because there's a lot in
it so the question that I was trying to
answer here in terms of estimating
sample size because I'm hoping to gather
enough responses that I am able to run
in forensics on this this data is
assuming total sample size and assuming
it's split equally between the two
groups so I'm talking about two separate
samples two independent samples how many
subjects are needed to ensure an eighty
percent chance so I'm looking to power
this at eighty percent of detecting a
clinically relevant difference between
the medians of the two groups because it
appears that we have a non-normal
distribution that implies that we may
want to consider using nonparametric
methods for estimating the sample size
and for doing the data analysis and when
you do nonparametric methods one of the
things that you do is you were looking
at medians you're not looking at means
which you would be looking if you were
looking at doing parametric work so what
is this clinically relevant thing here
how do we know it when we see it there's
a difference a statistician might tell
you this test or this this process will
allow you to detect a 1-point difference
on your scale well that might be great
but that might not be clinically
relevant whether somebody scores a
whether the median is 49 or its 50 may
not make much difference to a
practitioner who's looking at this
material so clinically relevant really
refers to what what is going to get
someone who reads a study to sit up and
go oh that that looks like it might have
made a difference so as you're doing
this estimation process and you can't
just run it through a calculator and
online
calculators and generated to two-sided
t-test with nonparametric data how do
you how you figure out what an
appropriate clinical effective and how
do you factor that into your sample size
estimation so I consulted with an ohsu
static a statistician and the method
that I am proposing or have used here to
estimate my sample size is based on
numerous discussions with ham and some
some additional reading and basically
the process is first of all as with all
all projects like this you would start
by determining our hypotheses so your
null hypothesis is that the presence of
medical scribes absence or presence
makes no difference one way or the other
in the trust the median of the trust
score that you're going to see your your
alternative hypothesis is that the
presence of the scribe shifts the median
of the trust score a certain amount to
the right it becomes even more skewed
you lose some of the tail but you gain
more at the upper end of the
distribution so that seems to be a valid
that seems to be a you know plausible
approach to this then what you do is you
approximate probability distributions
for each of these hypotheses so I'm
going to jump right down here to the
print out and ignore this for vs2 we
actually modeled for different cases at
varying levels of probability so that's
an artifact from that but if you just
concentrate on the fact that this is the
null hypothesis you can see that we
first of all we bend the we've been to
the median scores starting at 32 and
running up to 51 and we put epoxy
because we know that it's skewed to
right and there's not much of a tail so
and 32 is well well below both the
median and the mean that we looked at
earlier so there's ten percent in this
bin ten percent in this and then you can
see the distributions start to go up as
you move to the right so this is
business you know you've got a fair you
have seventy percent here in the
the first two bins and the other thirty
percent down below and and that produces
a mean that was very close to what we
looked at the previous couple of slides
as far as what she was ova found in her
primary care distribution and the median
of 47 then we take this alternative
hypothesis and we make some assumptions
about what if the trust score the median
of a trust score shifts to the right the
distribution might look like that and
you can see now there's nothing down
here in these first two bins in this
tale and we have shifted the
distribution more to the right so you
can't on the one hand you can't just
willy-nilly just pick a distribution or
you can but you shouldn't this has to
pass the sniff test right it needs to be
something that looks like it could
really happen but you're still making a
guess in terms of what your what
parameters you're putting into this
program in order to generate your your
sample size so what comes out of this is
something called the p order you can see
here at 0 point six five six and the p
order is a measure if you will of the
effect size you're measuring the
distance of this p order from point five
which would be if there's no change it's
essentially the your null hypothesis so
its associated if you look the change in
the median here with a four-point effect
size so okay hold that plot for a minute
and it produces a total sample size of
94 patients that would be the total
number split be to group to group that's
what 47 / group is what i would need to
study and after i sent we ran a number
of these scenarios in simulations this
seemed to give us both a reasonable
distribution of what the the new-look a
change or the alternative hypothesis
would generate it gave us a four-point
effect size which based on conversations
both was a statistician and with
providers seemed to be a acceptable that
would be something that we get
somebody's attention
the median shifted four points and it
gave me a reasonable sample size with
within which to work as I don't have
five years to do this study so it's this
balancing act right to develop your your
sample size and I wanted to be really
transparent with you about all of the
underlying assumptions there okay so now
we have we have a number it now if you
recall when I talked about observation
and interviewing I mentioned that I
wanted to observe an interview six about
sixty patients and the reason I said 60
is that if we're looking at the 47 I'm
going to assume that they're going to be
some patients that I observe who may not
complete the survey and so this that's
60 is a little bit of a buffer it's
weird a little extra there of 13
patients so that I can have a reasonable
expectation of achieving the sample size
so I need in order to get statistical
significance on it okay so moving along
Sarge data analysis I will generate
descriptive and inferential statistics
of the overall trust scores for each pay
of the two patient groups using a
wilcoxon rank-sum test which is the
nonparametric equivalent of the
two-sided t-test and I'll run it at a
ninety five percent confidence
confidence interval will see what falls
out as well as descriptive statistics of
the demographics for both patient groups
on to the 21 c which is examine
relationships between patient
perceptions escribes in patient
demographic variables saying groups I'm
I have observed and now administered the
questionnaire to right after we did a
questionnaire we spend another five to
ten minutes and do another qualitative
gathering of data to elicit pace patient
perceptions of scribes and to
triangulate the observations and the
quantitative day or the questionnaire
data collected in order to again add
validity and richness to the description
of what's going on with medical scribes
and
to recall one of the one of the steps
during observation phase one or yet that
preparation phase was to develop the
interview guide for this similar to
observation I will do transcriptions of
audio recorded interviews and then I
will be doing the primary coding on this
identify themes and subscene and I'll
bring in again a couple or three people
who are subject matter experts in order
to support the validity help with the
triangulation and the same building and
then do member checking again with with
folks who have not been involved at that
point in the research to as a double
check on what we're doing make sure that
we're not going too far off the rails
okay moving on to evaluation so just to
summarize the data analysis two outputs
by specific aim are these qualitative
things around characteristic subscribing
assistant encounters and similarly
qualitative themes on one see around the
patient respect section describes the
command the interviews the qualitative
description of patient behaviors based
on the characteristics that I identified
in observation one and the statistics
that I I just went through front for the
questionnaire and those will be pulled
together into the final report which
will include essentially comparisons of
of all of these things so I'll be
comparing I'll be qualitatively
describing what ascribed assisted what
private encounters the characteristic
subscribers the student encounters and
how they differ from non scribus istered
encounters I'll be comparing the overall
patient trust scores for the two groups
I'll be looking for relationships or at
relationships between the perceptions of
the qualitative data gathered during the
interviews and patient demographics and
doing a comparison of the overall
patient chart scores based on it on the
two groups I'm sorry not non the two
groups but comparing those with the
patient perceptions of scribe to see if
there are any relationships as we can
tease out there I'm also considering
doing a comparison of my ob/gyn
results with both primary care results
again we know that there may be some
issues there so stay tuned and then
finally looping this all back to the
reason that we're doing this in the
first place which is to be able to give
bud garrison and Robbie Berg's from some
some thoughts and some ideas and some
guidance much needed guidance about
things that they may or may not have be
aware of when using medical scribes and
looking at the effect subscribes on
patient care so few obvious limitations
one site so although very valid and very
rich within that one site you can't
generalize that and say that that
applies to all OBGYN clinics in academic
medical centers female patient
participants so we're losing the male
component of this obviously the
uncertainty of the probability
distributions that are on underlying the
sample size estimation is is a big
factor when we're looking at the
evaluation of the the questionnaire
results and again that both as a result
for primary care results may not be
comfortable to my OBGYN because of the
variation in the patient populations
challenges gaining access to the OB GYN
clinic reducing reactivity during
observations so when you observe
something by step into the room not only
is the patient aware that they describe
their they're aware that that there's an
observer there and I discussed this with
ob/gyn and several folks have indicated
that because we're a learning
institution patients particularly on
return visits or who are seeing
providers where they've already
established care don't think that
reactivity is going to be a huge issue
but you have to be aware of it achieving
sample size is needed for the
questionnaire statistical significance
is also potentially a challenge if I
don't even make those 60 numbers still
things we can do with the data but we'll
be able to run these inferential
statistics and then always teasing out
confounding variables because you
measure the trust and you look at the
scores and you how do you know that it's
actually described that as creating the
effect
it could be it could be the color of the
providers skin it could be the reason
for the visit it could be any other
number of things and so we have to
investigate that and make sure that we
bring those all to this to the server so
that's my presentation and so many
people have already helped me with us
and I want to thank all of you and again
want to thank all of you for coming and
listening to me and hopefully it was
somewhat interesting I am happy to take
questions yes in there hasn't been one
thing I kind of glossed over didn't get
into a lot of detail in this but that we
do look at when we're looking at how
scribes interact is that there are
actually different models for providers
scribe interaction and as I said in
general the provider of companies I mean
describe accompanies the provider into
the room there are some circumstances
that I know of where the scribe actually
stays outside the room the provider has
the conversation and comes out and
essentially dictates to describe what
the scribe losses there is the ability
to actually see what the interaction was
because they may pick up on things as
described that they may want to ask the
provider about later so that's certainly
or their Telus cribes is another
mechanism that that some folks are using
even when you have the provider in the
scribe in the room thus far we've we've
found at least 22 different ways of
interacting one is that the provider
completely ignores the scribe and just
focuses on the patient there's no
conversation between the provider and
describe another is where there is
interaction between the provider and
described during the visit and that may
one of my hypothesis working hypothesis
is that that is a factor that makes a
difference I did some observation at one
point and was very interested and this
is to start to give you an idea of how
how the observation guide will become
developed I noticed that there was a the
scribe was not just focused the computer
but really focused on the provider and
at the patient and all of the described
doesn't interact with a patient at all
there there was a sense that I perceived
of described being very invested in what
was going on and so if you have that
sort of patient proceeds that there's a
level of engagement there it may see
that as a good thing that may actually
support trust or if they see that the
pig described is kind of detached that
may make them feel some something else
but that's a great question there there
there hasn't been there haven't been any
studies that i have found thus far that
addressed that that issue but it is
something certainly as a technique that
is being used other questions yes push
the button please
so my question is you mentioned that you
were looking at it as kind of a setting
powder looked at what's the what's your
opinion about how trust changes wanted
to delay add a single patient has
multiple encounters with the position
subscribe to one that's a great question
i it's really beyond the scope of this
study but that would be a logical next
step is to look at how trust changes
over time based on the scribe and based
on the fact that the scribe may change
right so you might go in as a patient
maybe you have an established
relationship with a provider and they're
using one scribe on one day the next
time you go back there might be a
different scribe there so there again a
lot of variables there thank you for the
questions beyond the falls on this
how're you going to control others I
can't I in terms of analysis I think
that some of that will be done as we
Randall analyzing the qualitative data
and we're starting to again bubble up
what those confounders are and I think
I'll be better equipped to know how to
to look at them do you have any
suggestions for how I might do that I
think the previous speakers for sure has
that's a huge thing with rose trusted
culture yeah it's pretty intuitive
minimum you need to collect you know
never been encounter its previous
encounters and get data on your
compounders you can't leave physics of
two groups with similar in their
composition of them better yet would be
if you could stratify us here as soon as
you're doing your [ __ ] cows are
viewing you could say okay I'm going to
take and I'm going to make sure the
twenty-five percent of my initial is to
twenty-five percent of people
established over four years and that
type of thing holy beings are thirty to
sixty your closing initially which i
think is a lot but I've chatted to try
and establish some of those variables so
I didn't
unless you do that you're really playing
a statistical yeah yeah it may be that I
need to limit limit listen up the
patience to only those who have
established relationships we don't want
any potentially any new or so it seems
the provider only one thank you actually
this is a good discussion how so so
first of all I think as a my question is
going to be about the mixed methods
nature of this studies it's actually
qualitative and quantitative there a
little bit separated but to address the
Aeons concern you could look at doing
some earlier qualitative analysis and
using that to inform the data collection
you do you know more quantitatively to
have in the mixer method however I I
want to say that I think this is
fantastic and that you can't you know
it's almost like you're trying to see is
there any single they're not explain the
nature of the signals right and so I
think that's okay you're trying to
understand this f is going on and on and
so not being able to adjust for
compounders is okay however measuring as
deion points out is going to be really
important for anything you think may
affect it and I might recommend that one
of the best ways to encourage that is in
your early analysis as you've gone
through a set of encounters before
you've done the rest you have some early
analysis to understand what you're
starting to see and then feed that back
in to sort of how you're collecting
information because that can really bind
the quantum and the qual together to
make it truly truly mixed method thank
you and making that qualitative
quantitative connectionist I'm
struggling with that a little bit right
now so thank ya dr. Lillian did you have
your hand
what the study is really is is a
snapshot and since we don't know
anything about we know very little about
the actual interactions and yet this is
also an exploratory study that that
charged new territory in addition to the
fact that trusts changes over time like
Annie mentioned very appropriately I
mean people coming in you know to these
encounters that debit studying also
bringing different levels of trust with
them so there's not just a post factor
you know in factor there's also a pre
confounding factor and again this study
is not able to to control for them
because it really isn't the kind of
longitudinal study that you want to see
you mean setting what it is going in in
a you know a bunch of impressions and
coming out and so I really want to kind
of emphasize that that looking for
confounding factors is not necessarily
the you know the focus of the study
because they simply cannot be controlled
for in a short duration of the original
study of this nature thank you
yes Dana
that's a great question of course i have
to submit a proposed observation guide
and an interview guide when i go for IRB
approval and i think that part of part
of what i understand how not having gone
through it before but haven't what I've
learned from talking up speaking with
others is you have to do a little bit of
Education I think it's better than it
has been in the past when they weren't
used to seeing so many qualitative
studies but educating the IRB folks who
are looking at your proposal that the
nature qualitative research is to be
iterative and that you want to have that
feedback loop where as you learn things
okay I'm a tweak that question a little
bit I think this is kind of trying to
read their mind which is a dangerous
thing but what they're looking for is
material changes that you would make and
certainly if there were material change
that have to I have to submit a
modification to it but I think if I can
if I can convince them that there might
be slight changes to the wording that
reasonably would not be perceived as
material any thoughts on that
right right
right no right it's primarily the what
am I looking for in the observation
which really is it's there's no
interaction there with the patient but
the interview guide is is what is likely
to evolve over time dr. Gorman just to
make a wonderful presentation very much
look forward to your results lots of
stuff that I'll email you but the script
respect to this I are being questioned I
want to say the IRB is our friend and so
I think that if we don't know what we're
going to ask patients and the IRB would
would like to see what we're going to
ask them then another strategy is simply
to say I'm going to figure this out and
I'll file a mod and I think because you
really don't yet know mm-hmm right and I
think they want to know and we want to
know that they think these are good
questions right and so forth I think
that's another way to do it is just say
I'm applying for this part and I'm going
to do this qualitative part but I can't
send you the questionnaire any better
than this nothing you'll bide with the
time comes another way to do thank you
yeah I'm able to catch I think I have in
the past sent a script of fork for
qualitative over and and sometimes where
the questions are fairly general and
then we'll note and will probe
appropriately you know what follow-up
questions and I haven't had to resubmit
the script every time there's some minor
change in the follow-up question so I
think just how you word it could make it
easier refer to already include whatever
that probing or follow-up question is
thank you
I think that during that first phase of
observations when although i'm primarily
focused on the clinical encounter there
will be hallway conversations and the
opportunity ask some of those questions
instead of a discovery mode as part of
the actual structure of the study it is
beyond the scope I really want to stay
focused on the patient with the patient
think and that's a great a very rich
area for for future research thank you
for the question by the way is a former
scribe yes for dinner is the gender of
the scribe denoted in your study it will
be good question Robbie is the manager
of the scribe program Harry at ohsu and
need to saying that that that all the
scribes currently in the department are
female have we had me escribes an ob/gyn
thank you
other questions if not thank you very
much I appreciate your attention and you
probably know why I do that I get a lot
of reading done on the bus